Hey how's it going bros
My name is Peeeewwwdiepie
And welcome to Pants On Fire
It's a little show that we shot while in Seattle for Pax
And we got to strap down our friends
For a lie detector test
And ask them the tough questions
It's the first kind of higher production thing we did for Revelmode
I'm really excited for it and I hope you will enjoy
*that's a cool transition*
Jack: Do you like having cream on your face? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° )
Felix: Pie me again!
Jack: Are you into kinky shit?
Jack, is green
*AWESOME INTRO*
Jack: Are you PewDiePie?
Felix: No (PEWDS) uh yes! Yes. *Jack laughing in the background*
Jack: Come on dude
Truth okay
Jack: *slams down cards, grabs the rolly thing* Shits about to get real
PewDiePie, (long pause) do you think you're the best YouTuber in the world?
Felix: Yes
Jack: Truth *lols*
Felix: Really?!
Jack: You egotistical asshole
Felix: OH NO
Felix: You heard it here first folks I'm the best YouTube channel ever!
Jack: Every YouTuber thinks they're the best
Felix: Yeah thats
Jack: Every YouTuber thinks they're hot shit
Felix: you got me on that one.
Jack: Did you dye your hair because you were jealous of me and Mark? *YEAH FELIX?*
Felix: I don't know what to answer!!
Jack: did you dye your hair cause you're jealous of me and Mark?
Felix: No.
Jack: Jury says no, bro
Felix: no fucking way, fuck you
Jack: *happy as shit* you jealous of my hair bro?
Felix: I am NOT jealous of your hair
Jack: You jealous of my hair bro?
Jack: You wanted a
Felix: What do you think I'm covering up?
Felix: I don't wanna look like you
Felix: Noone wants to look like-- AAH!
You slapped my hat! T^T
You hit me (oh no)
You son of a bitch!
Jack: It was  lie.
Felix: No
Jack: What's it smell like?
Felix: OKAY FINE I'LL ADMIT!
Jack: Smell it
Felix: Okay fine I'll admit it
Jack: Smell it!
Jack: SMELL IT!!!!!!
Felix: I wanna be- I wanna be-
*Smells it*
ouch
Felix: I wanna be like you Jack
I just wanna be like you!
*Jack be like I'm not taking this shit*
My face burns, it really hurts, is this, what is in this?
Jack: Do you copy Filthy Frank?
Felix: No...
Is that like a makeup channel?
Is that? Is that a-
Jack: I don't know
Felix: Does she do that-
Jack: I think the answers somewhere inside this
Felix: is she like uh one of those uh diy channels?
Jack: Maybe, hey how's it going?
Felix: can I get a kiss?
Jack: *mwah *SMASHES PIE IN FACE**
Felix: No my hair!
Why would you do that?!
Jack: I HAVE TO COVER UP THE COPYING!
Jack: That's a truth lie
Maybe you get half a pie then
Felix: What do you meann?
Felix: What do you mean (a bunch of times)
Jack: It was a truth lie!
*Jack enjoying the shit out of this*
Felix: What the fuck, that's worse
I HATE YOU!
Jack: Do you hate me?
Felix: Yes.
*sorry Jelix shippers*
Felix: What is it?
Jack: Truth
Felix: I KNEW IT! FUCK YOU!
Jack: Do you like having cream on your face?
Felix: yea...
Jack: Really?! You're into this?
Felix: I guess
jack gets some ideas...
What's wrong with you??
Felix: I guess I am, pie me again!
Jack: Are you- are you into kinky shit?
Felix: I mean
Jack: What are you?
Felix: I'm tied up, I'm creamed, I gotta boner...
Jack: Do you have a boner right now?
Felix: No, I wish
*Jack dying of laughter*
Felix: What the fuck is this??
You wanna check that bro?
Come on!
Jack: Creams hiding it, I can't see
Jack: Well you did say you like cream on your face
Felix: Give it to me!
I think I ship them now ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Felix: What the hell are we shooting here?
Jack: We have 4 more pies dude
Jack: Do you think you saved Ken's channel
*Felix thinking intensely* Wait what?
Jack: He's right there don't lie
Felix: is it not dead?
*MOTHERFUCKING KEN COMES OUT YEAHH!! SHIT GOT REAL*
Felix: Heyy...
Ken: I'd really like to hear this for myself
Jack: Did you save Ken's channel?
Felix: Uhh.. Yeah?
Felix: aw shit....
Jack: It's a lie
Ken: I think he needs a pie
Felix: Please, I thought we were friends
* a one smash*
Ken: Awe you did it
*a two smash*
*instant replay*
creepy laugh
Felix: Jokes on you, BITCH!
*AHAHA YOU MISSED JACKABOY*
*And Jack goes for the steal and!*
*changes his mind* *Felix looks like a crazy dude*
*CREAM FIGHTT!! EVERYONE'S DIRTY WITH CREAM *
Jack: You fucking asshole!
Jack: This has been PewDieLie, stay safe